so in light of recent events with
regards to the Logan trailer I figured
now would actually be a pretty good time
to cover the first story arc of x23 and
all new all different Marvel and I had
actually thought about skipping over
this but I think that for the sake of
completion it can't really be a bad
thing to go ahead and just throw it in
at the very least it gives us a more
comprehensive understanding of where
Laura Kenny resides operating under the
mantle of Wolverine in the all neww all
different Marvel Universe now for those
of you guys who don't know again all new
all different Marvel is not really a
reboot so much as it is a continuation
of things that took place before Secret
Wars and with x23 of course as we know
with my video on her character her
origin story and so on she was created
to be a clone of wolver rain but she was
made a female instead of a male due to
the fact that the original genes that
were supposed to be used to clone wolver
rain had basically degraded now again
this all goes into the origin story of
her character which is a link you'll
find down in the description but the
entire basis behind this is the idea
that after you know escaping from her
original facility spending time with the
X-Men spending time under tutelage of
the original Wolverine x23 had run into
this this sort of uh existential crisis
I guess in terms of her place in the
Marvel Universe and so she had
effectively struck out on her own Now by
stricking out on her own what it did is
it gave Marvel the opportunity to kind
of start moving her around to different
teams and different groups having her
interact with them and see which one
proposed The best scenario for her
character's placement within Comics as
far as fan reception and sales but what
this also did is it allowed Marvel to
begin segueing her into a relationship
with Warren Worthington now something to
keep in mind here is that this Warren
Worthington is not the Warren that we're
used to from Marvel Comics with regards
to Archangel his history with apocalypse
and so on this is the Warren Worthington
the younger version of angel from the
allnew X-Men line of stories now for
those of you guys who are relatively new
to Marvel Comics uh in the events
leading up to the secret War storyline
writer Brian Michael Bendis had
introduced all new X-Men in response to
the modern-day Cyclops having gone ay
and basically become Magneto and the
goal was for beasts to introduce them to
their younger selves in hopes that it
would sort of bring cyclops back it
would show him who he used to be versus
how far he's fallen but what this did is
it basically gave us a new line of X-Men
Publications which actually proved to be
pretty popular in the beginning the all
new X-Men were wildly popular when they
first came out the stories kind of
faltered here and there but again it
gave us a younger Cyclops it gave us a
younger Iceman which is what the new
Iceman line of stories is based on uh it
gave us you know a younger waren
Worthington in the midst of their
various interactions with the rest of
the Marvel Universe uh buddy
relationship began to form so to speak
between x23 and uh an Angel and the idea
that was kind of left to us is you know
will they get together will they not get
together but ultimately they did and
what this new line of all new Wolverine
stories focuses on is partly Laura
Kenny's life but also how she interacts
with her boyfriend Warren now the way
the story initially picks up is it
starts out in Paris France and we're not
really given much of a backstory here
and in truth we don't need to be because
this is really just an example of the
story kind of kicking off in the midst
of things that are already happening but
what ends up happening here with regards
to Tom Taylor's writing is someone had
basically tipped off Lura Kenny to the
idea that an assassination was going to
take place in Paris France and her goal
was to try to prevent this assassination
from happening now the reason why lur
Kenny currently operates as a
traditional superhero which is to say
fighting the good fight and not really
being an anti-hero like the original
Wolverine was was because she's trying
to distance herself from that history
she recognizes that she is a clone of
the original wolver rain but she's also
come to believe that he made a lot of
mistakes with regards to his life that
led him to the point where he ended up
dying after being encased in adamantium
and so for no other reason than the fact
that she doesn't want to end up with the
same fate she's basically begun to move
away but at the same time her history is
a very dark one in the sense that as a
child she was forced into prostitution
after escaping from the original
facility during her time in the facility
she was used to kill various people and
so even if it's not directly tied into
attempting to eliminate the same fate as
Wolverine himself it can also be assumed
that she's trying to effectively outrun
her past that she's trying to move away
from who she used used to be and become
somebody else in its entirety now
because of the fact that she's trying to
stop this assassination having all the
same Powers as Wolverine with a couple
differences in terms of how her claws
exist in the sense that she has she has
a claw in her feet as opposed to uh the
original Wolverine who only had three in
his hands and she has two in her hands
for the most part she still functions in
the same capacity but while she tries to
save this man who you know has had a hit
put on his life uh she ends up being
shot with a rocket and so when she comes
to it seems as though she's died and she
actually encounters the original
Wolverine now this was a very important
Moment In The allnew Wolverine line of
stories and the reason why I say that is
because not everyone who liked Laura
Kenny liked her being the new Wolverine
there were some people that just wanted
to see her stay her own character they
wanted to see her stay as x23 trying to
find her place in the world and they
wanted to see the original James howlet
stay as Wolverine but the idea of having
this conversation between the two of
them is effectively you know James
howlet passing the torch saying I'm not
Wolverine anymore I'm dead you are now
Wolverine not only that he also goes on
to tell her that he's made a lot of
mistakes or he did make a lot of
mistakes when he was alive he killed a
lot of people sometimes he killed them
in anger but he was really more prone to
acting irrationally or acting on his own
impulses as opposed to thinking things
through and being intelligent and you
know having having a a strong mind when
it came to whether or not he needs to
actually do something x23 is not that
way she's intelligent she thinks her
decisions out she doesn't just pop her
claws go into a frenzy and start tearing
stuff up and so he basically says that
that she is better than he ever was that
she's a much better version of Wolverine
than he was now again this is why this
was a source of contention among fans
because the Die Hard James howlet fans
did not want to see this happen and they
were angry about this idea they were
outraged at the idea that wolver rain
would cast himself aside even after
dying and say you can be the new
Wolverine now I'm I'm not that great I
was never that great of a superhero you
are better than I was a lot of
traditional Wolverine fans you know
James Hans didn't like that but the fact
remains this is Tom Taylor basically
telling us that for the foreseeable
future the original James Hallet is
never going to come back the new
Wolverine is Laura Kenny the new Logan
is Old Man Logan and that's just pretty
much where the allnew all different
Marvel landscape resides right now now
that may change later on I mean you know
in coming books people come back all the
time and so it's entirely possible the
original Wolverine May return but for
right now we have Laura Kenny and so
after she comes to she also realizes
that the rocket was shot from the top of
the Eiffel Tower and so she Dawns her
Wolverine costume much to the surprise
of almost everybody around her and she
immediately descends to the top of this
place now this is where Tom Taylor
starts to spin out into the story and
start building a bigger picture because
for Laura Kenny she doesn't kill unless
she has to which is a huge difference
between her and the original James
howlet again the original James howlet
would kill no questions asked for Laura
Kenny she doesn't do that she tries to
talk things out she tries to be a good
person and this is what happens
throughout this entire conflict with
this this unknown person she says look
like you have to stop we can talk about
this we can figure out what's going on
if you're being forced to do this we can
bring you away from that situation take
you in hiding you know whatever the case
may be but then suddenly in the midst of
their of their conflict they're set upon
by what seemed to be French police and
so in the midst of this this unnamed
person basically says that you know she
doesn't feel pain she doesn't feel any
sort of feeling whatsoever and while it
does take Laura Kenny by surprise this
unknown person jumps off the Eiffel
Tower and seems to effectively commit
suicide now while x23 also jumps off in
an effort to escape she's again rescued
by the uh the younger version of Warren
by you know the allnew X-Men's uh Warren
Worthington and so this is basically Tom
Taylor refreshing us saying yes the two
of them are in a relationship together
they are a couple and while they do you
know engage in a little bit of relation
here and there in terms of how they talk
to one another and so on it's also Tom
Taylor's telling us that waren
Worthington is as much a supporting
character in her line of stories as he
is you know a member of the Marvel
Universe in and of itself and so when a
drone seems to have been sent to destroy
this person who's in this uh in this
limousine the person who was supposed to
be assassinated when lur Kenny
intercepts it of course she comes Crash
Landing down to the ground and again she
does have some injuries and and nothing
real you know nothing really terrible
here that she can that she can't escape
from but this allows Tom Taylor to have
her and Warren travel to the corpse of
the girl who jumped off the Eiffel Tower
and it's revealed to us that x23 had had
suspected this but wasn't sure but it's
revealed that this girl is basically x23
that she seems to be a clone and so the
question that Laur Kenny has is where
did she come from who did this and who
made her and so in her investigations in
her search to find answers this leads
her to a place called alemx genetics now
within Marvel Comics you have several
corporations that are very seedy and do
some really bad things roxon is
basically at the top of the list roxon
is about as bad as it gets when it comes
to corporations they're engaged in
corruption assassinations all different
kinds of things there's especially a
main focal point right now in Jason
aon's run of the Mighty Thor which is
amazing but you know with regards to the
x23 line of stories alchemax uh has his
own Prison Complex alamax is really has
its fingers on everything but alchemax
genetics there's really this New Concept
in the sense that they've begun diving
into the realm of cloning people or
creating enhanced humans and so what
happens is that when x23 gets here
alchemax is a little suspicious owing to
the idea that you know whoever these
people are that are engaging in these
assassinations because they look like
lur Kenny you know alax's idea is that
they may try to infiltrate the genetics
compound and so to this guy you know
Captain Mooney he basically Cuts Laura
Kenny with the idea of verifying that
it's actually her simply because these
people who are who are clones of her do
not seem to have healing factors hence
the reason that girl died when she
jumped off the Eiffel Tower and so when
Laura Kenny's cut and she heals the
indication here is that it is Laura
Kenny and so from here Captain Mooney
takes her to a guy named Robert Chandler
and Robert Chandler is kind of like the
you know the Abraham Cornelius slj
Sublime of alemx in the sense that you
know Abraham Cornelius and John Sublime
were the ones behind the original James
howlet being transformed into Wolverine
by way of the weapon x project with this
particular alemx genetic situation
Robert Chandler is the one who's heading
the show and what he says is that
because of the capabilities of x23
because she she was such a formidable
character in her own right that after
the death of James how after the death
of the original Wolverine because he was
encased in adamantium and there's no way
of cracking adamantium once it hardens
it was impossible to access his genes
and so they looked to Laura Kenny as the
next best thing which in truth she very
much is she's pretty much the next best
thing from uh from Wolverine himself and
in some cases maybe better depending on
you know what situation we're talking
about but the idea was to clone her and
then for these clones to be used for
various reasons now the idea that
alchemax is putting forward is that
these clones were not going to be used
for nefarious purpose they were going to
be used as bodyguards so that when you
know diplomats went on various missions
across Seas you know or when they went
into the public that there would
basically be a lore Kenny beside them to
ensure their protection but what he also
tells us is that they are not the same
as x23 in the sense that they don't have
healing factors in the sense that they
don't have claws and so they do have the
same frighting prowess but according to
Robert Chandler they lack all the other
capabilities that Laura Kenny has and so
the task that's been set to x23 to all
new Wolverine is to basically track
these girls down in order to try to
bring them back in now for alchemax does
send I guess a couple agents after her
to basically follow her and to lead them
to uh to where these girls are x23 is
able to take them out immediately but
following this she travels back to her
place of residence to her own apartment
in the Bronx but when she gets there she
also picks up a scent that she doesn't
recognize only to find out that there's
a young girl named Gabby inside now
Gabby is a girl that we talked about
during our discussion on uh you know x23
versus Old Man Logan but that was the
second volume of the x23 line of stories
and so what this does is this allows us
to actually provide some clarity on
Gabby's character for those of you guys
who were asking questions on what her
basis is you know what her backstory is
and where she came from and so Gabby
being here is is designed or I guess she
she's here of her own intention but she
also tells us that she was basically the
one that sent the note the anonymous
letter to x23 telling her that you know
one of the sisters one of these these
four girls who would escape this
compound was going to assassinate that
man in addition to this we also learned
that when these four girls escaped that
because they had been subjected to such
heinous acts at the behest of Alx prison
their goal was to basically kill off all
these different people from alemx
genetics their goal was to basically
bring alemx genetics crashing to the
ground with their sight set ultimately
on Robert Chandler and so again you know
this is an instance whereby Gabby is
trying to let x23 know what's going on
but then tries to make an escape by
telling lur Kenny that she had set her
room on fire but when lur Kenny comes
back after realizing that it's just a
plate with you know a burning napkin
Gabby seems to have escaped now because
of the fact that lur Kenny has such a
strong sense of smell because again she
has all the capabilities as the original
wol rain she basically tracks down Gabby
and she finds them in the sewers below
New York and when she gets there she
finds three other sisters that are that
are taking up residence and these are
the ones that have basically escaped now
we will learn a little more about them
as things go on but these sisters are
very very skeptical of what's going on
it doesn't seem as though they initially
know that this is Lura Kenny but they
pick up on this fact almost immediately
not only that they basically shoot her
and subdue her now this is really
important because it tells us a couple
things when it comes to the character of
wolver rain depending on who's writing
the story sometimes wolver rain's
completely unfazed by bullets and other
times wolver rain is phased by bullets
when it comes to Lor Kenny it's much the
same way there's been times where Laura
Kenny's been shot and bullets don't
phase her whatsoever she's been shot in
the head and she's fine there's been
other times like this where she's shot
and she falls unconscious so don't
really take this particular situation of
her being knocked out by way of bullets
as an absolute truth truth because in
comics it really just depends on who it
is that's writing the story at the time
but when she comes to she's basically
tied up by the sisters and they begin
interrogating her but they also begin
saying things like what Laura Kenny's
been told isn't necessarily 100%
accurate if she's being told simply by
Alx genetics then there's more to the
picture regardless of what it was that
they said to her indicating that
alchemax has their own you know agenda
you know goals that they're trying to
achieve by taking these sisters back but
before this conversation can continue
any further the group is suddenly met by
the arrival of uh of Captain Captain
Mooney now of course Laura Kenny had
picked up his arrival she'd heard his uh
his troops coming she'd picked up his
scent and warned the rest of the sisters
to arm themselves because there was
going to be a conflict but once these
soldiers arrive again you know the other
sisters have no problems with killing
every single one of these guys but lur
Kenny tries to tell them not to she says
look you have to stop killing them you
can't just kill people like this you
know there's always a better way to
solve your problems the issue with this
is that once all these people are
subdued and once Captain Mooney is left
unconscious where one of the sisters
where balana basically intends to deal
the killing blow to uh to Captain Mooney
the group's suddenly met by the arrival
of Taskmaster now there are certain
circles in Marvel Comics of fans who
love Taskmaster he's actually a pretty
cool villain to be honest but
taskmasters claim to fame is that he's
quite possibly the best fighter in the
entirety of Marvel Comics x23 we're
actually going to see here in a little
bit is able to get the upper hand but
when it comes to a a long drawn out
fight between a person and Taskmaster
Taskmaster will almost always gain the
upper hand and the reason why is because
his fighting style is a mishmash of
almost all fighting styles in existence
not to mention that the longer he fights
a person the more he basically becomes
them in their fighting style he's able
to predict their movements he's able to
know what moves they're going to make
counter those moves accordingly uh he's
very prodigious not to mention he's
basically the trainer for almost every
single super villain that has the
ability to fight with any sort of
martial arts or any real fighting
prowess of any kind and so during this
conflict with x23 he immediately starts
to get the upper hand and he's basically
able to uh to counter her every single
blow but when he blocks one of her feet
she suddenly sends one of her claws out
and uh and pierces his hand and this was
actually pretty funny to me he was
actually pretty hilarious in the sense
that he was uh he was going through
saying you know I can counter every move
you make I can predict every single one
of your moves and then as soon as you
grabs her foot her claw pops out and
punctures his hand and so because of
this you know she basically she seems to
knock him unconscious you know and just
and leave him there and while the other
sisters do intend to kill you know
Taskmaster in the end they basically
just shoot him in the kneecaps so that
he can't follow them uh for the most
part he basically can't track them down
and so what they do is they jump into a
vehicle and it seems as though they're
going to make their escape either
traveling back to alemx or at the very
least uh you know give lur Kenny the
ability to kind of talk them down but in
the midst of all this they're tracked
yet again by Captain money and this is
when x23 comes to the realization that
Captain Mooney when he had gone and he
had cut her in order to verify who she
is had actually planted a tracking
device inside of her arm which is how
they were able to locate her in the
first place when they were in the sewers
below New York and so during this time
she's able to cut the tracking to bya
but not only that because it seems that
she's the only one that has any real
measure of fighting prowess in addition
to a healing factor and adamantium Claus
she basically tells the other sisters to
go about their business you know to to
get out of the way and she'll take care
of Captain Mooney what she is successful
in doing she's successful in
incapacitating him basically just kind
of leaving him there and so after this
we pick up with the other sisters one of
whom seem to have been injured in the
extreme and so because of the fact that
laori Kenny herself is not a doctor
because she doesn't know how to how to
treat a person effectively and because
this version of Lura Kenny does not have
a healing Factor they basically travel
to the residence of Doctor Strange now
this is one of the coolest moments in
the
story because it shows us just how crazy
things get in the realm of Doctor
Strange when they go into his office one
of the funny things is balana keeps
saying that the cupboard is winking at
her which is entirely possible in the in
the home of Doctor Strange there's God
only knows what's going to happen inside
that place it's it's uh it's absolutely
crazy but when Doctor Strange comes out
he's kind of shocked to see that there
are basically three girls inside this
home that look exactly like Laura Kenny
and so his first question is who are
these girls and then he uses his uh eye
of akamoto to look into who they are
look into their past and begins to
realize that yes they are clones of Lura
Kenny but they are also people who have
been manipulated and who have been uh
controlled in a multitude of different
ways for the for their own ends of alemx
and so what ends up happening here is
Doctor Strange ultimately agrees to help
after looking into the past of Laura
Kenny and uh and seeing that she came
came from the same history as these
girls but Lor Kenny was able to harness
this rage that she had and use it for
something constructive and so the idea
is that these girls can do the same
thing as well but in the midst of their
conversation we suddenly hear gunshots
from the other room and when they go in
there they realize that balana was
freaking out over the cupboard that was
winging at her and shot the cupboard and
in doing so had basically broken the
Seal of this cupboard which houses what
Doctor Strange refers to as Horrors
which just unleashes this massive
monster and so in response he throws lur
Kenny and
and the other sisters are able to
basically subdue this giant monster but
it's just it was really entertaining to
me because I like what's going on with
Doctor Strange where he's not super
serious he's actually you know partly
comedic and partly serious in these
stories but it's also really
entertaining to see all these different
things you know kind of unfold and uh be
explored on their own but the fact
remains here that because Doctor Strange
is at his core you know a neurosurgeon
despite the fact that he is really more
of the sorcerer Supreme than anything
else he basically teleports the group to
a hospital and he takes you know Laura
Kenny alongside uh Zelda into this room
and they begin going through and trying
to figure out a way to uh to bring Zelda
you know to to make her healthy again
but what we find out is that Zelda isn't
necessarily dying because of her
injuries Zelda is dying because she has
nanites inside of her body and so what
Doctor Strange says is this is beyond
his ability to take care of that what
they need is someone who is well-versed
in science that can enter the body of of
Zelda and combat all these nanites and
effectively just get rid of them in
their entirety and so what happens is he
teleports them away to the basee of
operations for Janet van for the wasp
and so once they get there they
basically explain the situation that you
know x23 had come across these three
sisters that she has you know one of
them named Zelda had been injured in an
escape from soldiers of alemx genetics
and that in the midst of all this that
you know Zelda was injured and she's
basically dying and so you know of
course she petitions janev van di to
help her janev van Dy uh you know
doesn't really uh agree with this in the
sense that the initial mission was to
actually steal the Ant-Man suit but
because janev van Dy is willing to help
here uh they basically jump in and they
begin going through the body of of Zelda
in order to find out where these nanites
are coming from what their purposes and
get rid of them the problem with this is
that as they're fighting these nanites
these nanites suddenly start sending out
uh basically a homing Beacon to alemx P
or alamax genetics which allows Captain
money and his forces to track down lur
Kenny and these three sisters and so
while the efforts of of lur Kenny and
Janet vany inside the body of Zelda are
successful and uh you know being able to
to destroy a large enough number of
these nanites that they can help cure
her of whatever it is that's killing her
in the end the arrival of Captain Mooney
and his forces means the death of Zelda
when Gabby does what she can to hold off
Captain Mooney but is thrown off and in
response Captain Mooney shoots Zelda in
the face killing her on the spot and so
following this the sisters are
effectively fed up they're basically at
at a point now where they realize that
there doesn't seem to be any way to get
past what it is that Alx wants to do
aside from killing these girls and so in
the end they basically switch outfits
that x23 switches outfits with balana
and in return they travel to the
facility of alchemax with the intention
of allowing them to to kill who they
believe to be uh x23 and then take the
other sisters and so when x23 gets to
the facility because of the fact that
she's disguised as balana as soon as she
goes in the you know the soldiers in Alx
prison kill her right off the bat but
because of the fact that this is x23 she
has a healing Factor and so once they
take her to the the base underground
once they uh seem to believe that she's
dead she immediately you know allows her
healing factor to kick in she comes back
and she goes through and starts
attacking almost everybody she sees not
only that she's able to uh make it to
the security room and open the gates for
the rest of the uh rest of the sisters
to come in and begin going through and
start attacking the the remainder of Alx
genetics and so for the most part this
is really just Tom Taylor kind of
wrapping things up showing us that it
doesn't seem as though there was any
real solution to this aside from you
know defeating Robert Chandler and
bringing alemx genetics down now again
you know x23 doesn't kill Robert
Chandler because this is very much
against her moral code instead she
incapacitates him and while Gabby did
want to kill you know Robert Chandler
while she was very close to killing him
what she also does here is she pops a
claw and this tells us that she does
have claws that contrary to what x23 had
been told contrary to what Laura Kenny
had been told Gabby does still seem to
have the same abilities as she does and
in hindsight to the end of the story it
actually makes sense because if you guys
noticed along the way there was never an
instance when when Gabby was injured
when she was shot when she ever really
engaged in any real measure of combat
instead she was usually off to the side
and it made sense at the time due due to
the fact that well she's a little girl
what could she possibly offer to the
situation and so we just kind of assumed
that was the case but it never really
dawned on me that Tom Taylor was
building up towards something bigger and
so because of the fact that she does
have have the ability to pop claws
because it seems as though she does have
a healing Factor something to also keep
in mind is she doesn't immediately tell
x23 this this this is the reason why
when we covered our story on Old Man
Logan versus x23 that Gabby had popped
her claws and shown you know Laura Kenny
that she did have you know claw which
took Laura by surprise but the fact
remains that because of the fact that
balana seems to have escaped and uh x23
has essentially taken Gabby under her
Wing to teach her how to be a hero on
her own that balana I guess her actions
pick up with someone that she's talking
to and we don't know who it is but we
learn that this person is basically
kaimur who was the original Handler for
x23 during her time in the facility
which indicat hates that she's going to
play a much larger role in the future of
the allnew Wolverine line of stories but
with that being said we're going to
bring this to an end uh if you guys
enjoyed this let me know how you guys
feel about you know the the current run
of allnew wolver rain in Marvel Comics
I'm actually a little curious here and
if you guys are new to Comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button
become part of the robore and uh drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace